I think you played uh Levy Gotham chess  with the with the Without a Queen was  that a thing I think that was a bullet  game yeah the one minute game I think so  yeah is that an actual thing that you  can pull off like would you be like Levy  or yeah get somebody like Levy in bullet  maybe I can win like 50 it'll probably  be what's bullet What's the timing on  the whole game one minute for the whole  game okay what about I mean how much do  you miss the queen if it's gone against  the international master  you know in a bowl game like I said  maybe in bullet I can maybe score 50 in  in a in a Blitz game or anything  anything slower maybe 10 maybe one out  of ten I can win me one out of ten yeah